first off congratulations on the movie
it really is a real honor to be able to
talk to you guys today so i appreciate
your time
so julie i wanted to start with you
because i was reading that you would
originally said that my life on the road
was an impossible book
to make into a movie so i was wondering
when that changed for you was it a break
story moment seeing your cast together
any specific thing like that
it was i have to do it it was like i am
so emotionally moved
by this i've never seen this put into a
movie before
i knew gloria and i just you know there
wasn't a choice i didn't have a choice
i had to do it i definitely respect that
i was wondering if it was going to be
the bus out of time concept though which
is a pretty genius way to connect
everything all together
thank you no that didn't come right away
but it was the hook
it was the key let's say it was the key
and is the hook
um i i had to find something that would
be the glue that would unify this 80
years of her life
that where i could move from all the
different gloria's easily but
i have a constant which is this
greyhound black and white
bus out of time or the four glorias are
always there and they can interact with
each other
and it is the most surreal um but also
introspective part of the movie
absolutely
gloria i was wondering if there was any
specific part of
your personal experience that people are
less familiar with
that you were just really excited to get
to tell but now
in the feature film format well i want
to speak to that bus out of time because
i also had no idea how julie could take
this
you know book and and make it into i
mean you know
that was entirely her invention and it's
so
genius because it's so intimate and
personal
and timeless and populist we can all
imagine ourselves
on a on a greyhound bus right uh the
part of the
movie that of course uh you know i think
we all
or many of us had mothers who were not
able to tell their own stories
and so the part that shows my mother is
actually the most
moving to me because she was not who
she could have been and those words what
might have been
are the saddest i think
that was an excellent part of the movie
i'm also a big fan of lula wilson so it
was really nice to see you use her
abilities to the max there
oh i need to learn to tap dance
i'm now i'm even more impressed by her
than i already was
gloria i also wanted to get your
impression on observing
julie work as a director on set not just
in terms of directing the movie and
being a storyteller but more so
as kind of like a leader of a group
working on
something together well i wasn't on set
except uh once in georgia
so i i didn't see her but i
have seen her work and
you know i think she's the movie-making
genius of our time you know so
only when other people have called up
and asked me something i didn't say yes
right away
but she said she i said okay you know
whatever it is that you want to do i
just had faith
in all honesty there might be and across
the universe over my shoulder right now
that is out of frame but it's there i
promise you
oh bless you gloria just recent she saw
it
um right before we started the movie she
didn't see it when it first came out
yeah and then i thought i mean it's
incredible i mean
who could put the entire
transcontinental piece movement
on film and she does so
julie one other specific thing i wanted
to ask you is if you ever considered
casting just one actor to play gloria
and then using cg
and makeup or was the idea always to
cast
multiple actors i knew that julianne
moore would play the gloria that we all
think we know
which is gloria from ms magazine onward
and i knew that you know i had done that
with frida freda was
selma from age 16 to 47 but
she was in the middle there she was 35
when she did it and we could do it
through hair and makeup
i didn't really want to try to do that
with julianne i felt that i was going to
have to have a six-year-old
lulu wilson is 12 and then i needed
someone like alicia vikander
to play 20 to 40 and it allowed me then
to have
the conversations between the ages i
think it's much more exciting to have
the glorious than gloria i will
definitely agree with that
uh gloria something else i wanted to ask
you about was
this movie and also mrs america kind of
address how
feminism is not an unchanging movement
and that different generations can
disagree on certain issues so kind of
wanted to know what you
think is the key to i guess
harmonious progress between generations
well it would be nice to have the truth
which mrs america didn't tell us
i mean they they sent me two of the
scripts and they sent eleanor smeal two
of the scripts too
and we read it and we realized the
premise was a total lie you know
that actually phyllis schlafly as far as
we could tell didn't change one vote
it was the insurance companies in the
economic interest that defeated the
equal rights amendment
so that show is the hen fight theory of
history
that women are our own worst enemies and
of course we disagree sure we disagree
but we are not our own worst enemies
hello
we have the worst enemies so
you know that that is is not comparable
at all and it's all the more important
i'm all the more grateful
that uh julie is there telling it like
it really is
i appreciate you sharing your take on
that the other thing i really wanted to
ask you because i think
a lot of people out there including
myself might need the answer to this
right now
is what would the hopaholic say for
anyone who might be
struggling with the pain of loss right
now and maybe they can't find a way to
forge forward or they think they can't
right now
well i would only say that um
hope is a form of planning hope is what
we have as a vision of the future
and if you allow that to be taken away
from you
then you're defeated from the beginning
so
it isn't that i'm blindly optimistic
though i
am hopeful but i do
treasure and value and and support
try to gain support in myself for hope
and that means being with people who
share your hopes
we are communal animals we're not meant
to be by myself by ourselves
and that's what social justice movements
are for
and i think i have time for one more so
julia i will ask you this
i really do think that this is a movie
that is very deserving of being seen on
the big screen
but what was your first reaction when
you heard that might not be the case and
over the course of this home release
have you found any silver linings to the
format
yes i mean i think honestly our
wonderful distributors roadside
attractions
really wanted it to go out into theaters
as did we because we had the joy
of having a thousand people at our
premiere in sundance
and then no more you know once or twice
but and and having that collective
experience of a lot of people
screaming clapping standing ovations
okay that ain't gonna happen
but the silver lining is a much wider
audience
people are captive they're looking for
smart fun
different things on television and i
think that this is
we we definitely wanted it to come out
be a month before the election we
hope to inspire people to do what gloria
does which is
out there vote become active
make the change that you want so that is
the silver lining that a lot of people
can see this now
i'm in lockdown with my family and i
can't wait to share it with multiple
genders
generations yes that's very happy about
that cool
thank you again so much for your time
today and a huge congratulations on the
movie
thank you thank you